let's talk about E&O insurance what is
you know insurance when does a filmmaker
need to begin the policy and other times
when a filmmaker will not need you know
insurance so you know insurance is an
insurance policy that filmmakers have to
get when their film is going to be
distributed in any way it stands for
errors and omissions and it covers
things like copyright infringement
trademark infringement personal rights
violations violations of rights of
publicity those things you can't touch
but which every filmmaker is susceptible
to if there is some sort of claim for a
copyright infringement or something of
that nature so that's what you know
insurance covers you for as to when you
get you know it really depends I think
Michael will say get it early all the
time would you say that well it's really
educating as early as you can I work on
a lot of films that are maybe so small
or just very discrete not controversial
at all a feature film that really is
just shooting in one or two locations
where there the risk of needing you know
is very low and they can wait until a
little bit later if they need to for
budgetary reasons if you're dealing with
the feelings a little more controversial
something that's out in the open that is
just dealing with a controversial topic
or something of that nature then you
should get it a lot earlier especially
if you're doing something without
permission so if you're doing a life
story on somebody be them alive or
deceased and you don't have the rights
from that person you very well will want
to get you know early because what it
will do is if that state comes
afternoons is hey you don't have the
right to do this you got to shut down
production you have your insurance in
place and it gives you the one the
confidence but to a limit on your
financial liability to say yes we are
doing this it's appropriate for us to do
a life story right we have a First
Amendment right to tell the story and by
the way we have an insurance company
that's backing us up and so it really
depends on the project how early you
need to get it but as early as possible
as Michael said is always prudent so
even within the the final draft of the
script or maybe more when it you're
about to start shooting some films we
recommend getting you know insurance
before the script is even done yeah I
think Dominique strauss-kahn
you mentioned before that was very early
and that was a very high risk and so
they wanted to have insurance in place
early cuz if it leaked that the script
was being written
someone could potentially try to stop it
yeah they on that one absolutely at the
at the script stage in fact that was a
condition of one of the financial
backers that the filmmaker had to show
proof of insurance for you know the
smartphone smartphone and seer in that
case do you have a list of carriers in
your book yes we do
okay great yes we have a list of brokers
brokers to be nuanced about it we have a
list of brokers they kind of go out to
the same carriers that will issue the
policy we have lists of great brokers
that are very proficient with
independent film documentary films and
fair use and make the process very easy
and so it would be similar to getting a
car insurance quote in some sense they
would go through different things find
out things I and what I like to tell be
I like to use is if somebody does
approach you and says you can't do this
with my permission before you have your
Eno in place that's a pre-existing
condition so it says if somebody goes to
get medical insurance and in a heart
condition the carrier will say sure
we'll cover you for everything but that
heart condition and it's the same thing
for film sure we'll help you for
everything but a claim from that person
who's already come forward and presented
a potential problem and if the filmmaker
were to conceal that there was a
pre-existing problem then that would be
later on down the line if something did
happen so just leverage no crime yeah
interesting is medical insurance you
know if you just if you don't disclose
something on your application that's
fraud and they won't it won't be
obligated to cover you
you